as the electric daisy carnival concludes
the traffic tomorrow morning is
especially expected to be a nightmare
madison kimbrough joins us live with
more on what you need to know for your
morning commute madison
expect heavy congestion on the northern
part of 215 also on las vegas boulevard
and right here on i-15 particularly
tomorrow morning around 6 a.m when edc
is set to end with that being prime time
for north las vegas residents to hit the
road for their morning commute so take
precaution and make sure to leave a good
15 to 30 minutes in advance now for
anyone traveling near the area of the
las vegas motor speedway please watch
out for other cars and pedestrians as
they may be people walking around from
the festival this is also going to
include those ride share vehicles and
buses as well if you're traveling from
areas such as henderson or southern
highlands even silverado ranch into the
central valley you shouldn't have any
issues again the electric daisy carnival
ends tomorrow morning so make sure that
you plan accordingly when you are out on
the roadway reporting near deserving and
i-15 madison kimbrough live local now